hi everyone I'm Alina osipova a customer
engineer and I'm once young also a
customer engineer and we both work here
at Google Cloud welcome to the technical
series for startups where we are
creating a series of videos for
technical enablement to help startups to
start build and grow their businesses
successfully and sustainably on Google
cloud in our previous video we learned
how you can innovate with machine
learning Solutions such as contact
center Ai and document AI
they are pre-packaged Solutions designed
for common use cases companies can start
using them without relying on AI experts
however if you start implementing custom
Solutions with AI experts in your team
you will start to face new challenges
and today we are going to Deep dive a
little bit more into how you can
Implement machine learning Ops on Google
Cloud we'll start by looking at some of
the challenges that startups face when
it comes to their machine learning
workloads following that we will
introduce the concept of ml Ops and how
ml Ops can be achieved on Google Cloud
we'll then walk through a demo of ml Ops
with vertex AI in the Google Cloud
console
and finally we will learn about one of
our customers and their ml Ops Journey
let's explore common challenges our
customers are facing when dealing with
ML workloads let's imagine that we are
walking with an advanced startup company
with AI and ml technical skills
employees have experience with
Frameworks tensorflow or pytorch and
even were able to deploy their models on
one of our compute options that we
covered in the previous sessions Cloud
run or Google kubernetes engine the
common challenges this company could
potentially face include models don't
make into production High degree of
manual and man of war no reusable or
reproducible components and many others
further we are going to explore how
vertex AI pipelines can help our
customers to overcome those challenges
why are ml workloads becoming so
challenging to handle over time is it
all because of the complexity of the
code
in reality only a small fraction of real
world ml system is composed of ml code
as shown by the small blue box in the
middle the required surroundings
infrastructure is vast and complex given
all the challenges that comes with
managing machine learning workloads how
can we best address them and help
eliminate the management overhead that
comes with this machine learning
workloads here we want to introduce the
concept of ml Ops but what exactly is
mlops just by looking at the name we can
guess that ml Ops is related to devops
to a certain extent
we can Define it as an ml engineering
culture and practice that aims at
unifying ml system development and ml
system operations
in other words ml Ops aims to prepare
infrastructure to streamline the
production process of ml systems such as
training testing deployment and
monitoring most importantly it is to
ensure that the process is consistent
scalable and repeatable within ml Ops
there are multiple stages involved and
it often goes in this sequence
first you start with your ml model
development once you have decided on
your model you will have to
operationalize your training by building
a training pipeline this includes
Gathering training data running your
training jobs and evaluating the
performance of your model
when your pipeline is up and running you
can conduct continuous training Whenever
there is fresh data or based on any
custom metric that you set
The Next Step will be to deploy a model
to a serving environment and prepare
your model to solve predictions SM model
is in production and serving clients in
real time you will need to continuously
monitor your model for any data drift or
performance degradation so that you can
intervene when needed finally at the
call is data and Model Management which
is essential to governing ml artifacts
to ensure auditability traceability and
compliance at the same time this can
also be used to promote shareability
reusability and discoverability of ml
assets
to get started with ML Ops on Google
Cloud we have vertex AI Vortex AI is
Google Cloud's unified machine learning
platform that allows you to create
deploy and manage models over time and
at skill
it is built on top of Google's robust
and secure Foundation
and provides flexibility for users of
all ml expertise whether you are new to
the domain or an ml expert
imagine that we have done our
exploratory analysis and build out our
model in our Jupiter notebook
we are now ready to operationalize and
productionalize our machine learning
workflow so what can we do to automate
the process of extracting and preparing
data as well as training and deploying
our model to do so we have vertex AI
pipelines that can help you automate the
end-to-end process allowing for
repeatability and scalability when it
comes to building your machine learning
models with pipelines you can easily
retrain your models at regular schedules
based on new data that comes in without
having to worry about infrastructure or
management overhead
if you are interested in learning more
about building your own pipelines with
vertex AI pipelines do check out the
link in the description box for a more
detailed video under the AI simplified
playlist
before you can start serving predictions
to your end users you will have to
deploy your trim model to an endpoint
for your users to access for this we
have vertex AI prediction that can
handle both online endpoints as well as
batch prediction requests
with vertex AI prediction you can deploy
model stream with either Auto ml or
custom code to serve online and batch
prediction requests depending on your
use case
[Music]
as vertex AI prediction skills
automatically based on traffic it
extracts away any form of infrastructure
overhead from the machine learning
Developers
on top of that you will be able to split
traffic between models and also
customize the endpoint machine types
based on your model needs
now let's move to the managing and
tracking the model quality
what is model monitoring and what
challenges does it help to solve model
monitoring helps data scientists and
machine learning engineer to answer the
question why does a deployed model
perform in a certain way
modern applications rely on
well-established set of capabilities to
monitor the house of their services
examples include software versioning
rigorous deployment processes event
login alert and notification of
situation requiring intervention
on-demand and automated diagnostic
tracing automated performance and
functional testing
vertex CI provides a host of products to
Monitor and govern your models all of
which helps drive both successful and
responsible AI deployment those Services
include monitor signals for model
predictive performance and alert when
those signals deviate diagnose to
identify the cause of deviation model
updating to trigger model retraining
pipeline integration with feature store
model monitoring is only one piece of
the envelopes puzzle I would like to
explain a bit more about train and
serving skill and data drift detection
it helps to answer the following
questions
why does the model perform differently
from the training time in the production
environment
this is called training service Q This
queue can be caused by a discrepancy
between how you handle data in the
training and serving pipelines a change
in the data between when you train and
when you serve and many other reasons
among them data drift is one of the
common causes of the skew data drift is
defined as variation in the production
data from the data that was used to test
and validate the model before deploying
it into production so you have to
monitor how significantly service
requests are evolving over time this is
called Drift detection
so now how do you manage and govern your
ml models here are some products that
you might find helpful first up we have
a feature store that allows you to share
and reuse ml feature across use cases
allowing you to serve ml features at
scale with low latency
on top of that Google Cloud also offers
ml metadata which enables you to
automatically track inputs and outputs
to all your components with this you
will be able to visualize analyze and
compare detailed ml lineage
lastly model registry is a central
repository where you can manage the life
cycle of your ml models from the
registry you can have an overview of
your models so you can better organize
track and train new versions of your
model when you have model versions that
you would like to deploy you can simply
assign it to an endpoint directly from
the repository to deploy it
explainable AI is fully managed service
on the vertex side that enables user to
generate what are called feature
attributions or feature importance
values for their model's predictions
feature attributions are an
explainability method that shows users
how much each input feature contributed
to their model's predictions and to the
model's overall predictive power
explainable AI is built into multiple
vertex AI Services users can currently
get feature attributions in vertex
prediction automl tables and vertex
notebooks
as a fully managed service xci is
flexible fast and scalable you can use
xai on models trained on tabular image
or text Data it works on models trained
using any ml Frameworks
non-to-stensorflow and we support both
online and batch prediction use cases
explainable AI provides insights to
improve the quality of the models by
refining the training data you can
identify mislabeled examples Active
Learning misclassification analysis and
providing decision support to your
stakeholders on top of that xci supports
tabular image text Data from any
tensorflow model fully managed
serverless and faster query
let's explore on how to manage and
govern a model in the next slide I hope
the above presentation help you to
understand more about Emma loves and now
I would like to show you them in action
for this example we are going to run a
simple pipeline to train ml model but
please remember that it's not only for
training with vertex AI pipeline it's
also possible to automate the entire
life cycle of a mail model such as
training test and deploying and
monitoring vertex pipelines before
creating the pipeline make sure that
necessary apis are activated and Google
Cloud Storage bucket created
to create a cloud storage bucket click
the create button in the cloud storage
dashboard first of all let's create a
cloud storage bucket go to the
navigation menu then cloud storage and
click create
name your bucket and choose where to
store the data Regional or
multi-regional let's create a
multi-regional bucket
the bucket is going to contain data
pipeline model and serving model
after creating a bucket make sure that
vertex AI API is enabled and necessary
permissions are granted to your account
to run the pipeline let's move on to the
vertex CI dashboard
let's create a user managed notebook
from vertex CI dashboard go to workbench
from the code repo I have an option to
deploy in vertex cyborg bench and that's
what I'm going to do
after initiating the process I can see
user manage notebook has been created
with tensorflow 2.8 environment
pre-installed you can do the same
manually from the console and then
upload your notebook with the pipeline
code
next let's open Jupiter lab and execute
the code
the current pipeline defined using
python apis the pipeline consists of
three components CSV example gen trainer
and pusher
let's take a look at the pipelines
function
example gen component brings data to the
pipeline
trainer component uses user provided
python function that trains a model
Pusher component pushes the model to a
file system destination then we Define a
runner to run the pipeline and finally
to meet the job
after the job runs successfully let's
explore the visual output we can see our
pipeline components let's select the CSV
Trend component and go to the node info
here we can see our input parameters and
our output parameters
the current pipeline is a good
simulation of the production-like
pipeline in the pipeline you can also
Define function based or container-based
components Google also provides
predefined pipeline components that you
can reuse for your pipeline when you
deploy the pipeline I would encourage
you to check if components you are
looking for already exists for more
information please follow the link in
the description
next part is artifacts artifacts pass
complex data like training data between
components let's expand one of the
artifacts as we can see it's no more
than a pass to our previous created
cloud storage bucket
you can monitor each component's CPU
utilization from the pipeline UI by
selecting component and go to YouTube
there are a few metrics you can see CPU
GPU and network that have been sent and
received by each component those metrics
could be leveraged to further optimize
your workload on the component level
now that we have our three model let's
import it into vertex AI model registry
a central repository where we can manage
the life cycle of our ml model
to do so head over to model registry and
click on import
select import as new model
alternatively if you have trained a new
version of an existing model you can
also choose to import as new version
give the model a name a description and
select a region
since my model is trained with
tensorflow 2.8 I will select import
model artifacts into a new pre-built
container and then choose the
corresponding model framework and
version for my container
next you will need to specify the cloud
storage directory that contains your
safemodel.pb file you can set up
explainable AI here but we'll skip this
for now and carry on to import the model
so with our model in model registry now
we are ready to deploy it to an endpoint
and start serving predictions
let's head over to endpoints and click
on create endpoint
give your endpoint a name
you'll be able to select either standard
access mode which makes the endpoint
available through rest API or private
access mode which uses a VPC Network to
create a private connection to the
endpoint
I want to be able to access it through a
rest API so I'll select standard
here we will select our model that we
imported
if we have multiple versions of our
model we can deploy them to one endpoint
and split the traffic between the
different versions
suppose you found a way to increase the
accuracy of your current model with new
training data you can add a new model to
the same endpoint to serve a small
percentage of traffic and gradually
increase the traffic split to the new
model 200 percent
since I only have one version I will
leave the traffic split at 100 percent
next we select the compute resources to
serve prediction traffic
I'll leave the minimum number of notes
at the default one next select the
appropriate machine type and the service
account
in the next section we can set up model
monitoring to monitor the performance of
our models as it starts to
self-prediction traffic
we will name the monitoring job for easy
identification set how frequently we
want the job to run I'll leave it as the
default at 24 hours
we can also set the monitoring data
window which determines the length of
the window to put prediction traffic
from
I'll leave it blank so that it will
default to the monetary interval
next we can set up alerting so that
relevant stakeholders can be notified
when a model exceeds the alerting
threshold
lastly we specify a sampling rate of 10
which is the percentage of prediction
requests within the monitoring window
that we want to sample
photo monitoring objective we can choose
to either detect training serving skill
or prediction drift so for demo purposes
I will select training serving skill
we will need to provide our training
data so that the monitoring job can
compare
then we specify the target column name
I'll leave the alert threshold as
default so it will be 0.3
finally we'll click on Create and we
will see that the status is shown as
deploying model
once it is successfully deployed you
will be able to monitor metrics related
to these endpoints in this dashboard
and so that brings us to the end of our
demo
let's look at one of our customers Apna
and their machine Learning Journey on
Google Cloud app now is a smartphone app
that leverages proprietary algorithms to
drive AI enabled matches between
candidate profiles and employers at a
hyper local level in just three years
Apna built one of India's leading
professional marketplaces on cloud
growing to 22 million users across 70
plus cities
with a combination of cloud SQL Cloud
pops up and bigquery Amna created a
pipeline for millions of daily data
points that are ready for vertex AI to
perform ml modeling the results of
running the platform on Google Cloud
manage infrastructure services and
vertex AI has been substantial
it is estimated that abna is compressing
the time to build AI models by 20
compared to how long it would take to
build from scratch using a traditional
data analytics engine as a result Apna
is able to Crunch up to 500 million user
interactions every day to power its
vertex AI enabled algorithms thanks to
the possibility of Rapid ml modeling on
vertex AI in a situation where
fraudsters constantly evolve
methodologies Apna is able to identify
and remove up to 60 percent of
inappropriate content on the platform
daily in this session we learn about ml
Ops and look at the various tools that
are available in vertex AI that can help
us incorporate ml Ops practice into our
ml systems
we also Deep dive into understanding how
to run pipelines and manage our models
with model monitoring in vertex AI
through a demo
and lastly we reviewed a customer
success story Apna and saw how Google
cloud and vertex AI helped them automate
their ml workflow to build out a
successful AI enabled platform if you
are interested in learning more please
click on the links in the description
box below where you will be able to read
out more on vertex AI check out our AI
simplified YouTube playlist
get Hands-On with the platform by trying
our step-by-step guided tutorials and
lastly please reach out and get
connected to learn more that brings us
to the end of this video in the next
video we will go over how you can
architect a retail startup with Google
Cloud how can Google Power your retail
business and how you can accelerate the
retail lifecycle with Google and that's
a wrap don't forget to like And
subscribe to our YouTube channel and
also to click on the Bell icon to be
notified whenever a new video is posted
hand tied and we'll see you very soon in
the next video
foreign
[Music]